ce
bonsoir à tous
elle bouleurs ne me trouve tellement
bien ici encore un rêve petite fille
j'avais des rêves des rêves direct des
rêves je n'ai encore et j'en aurais
encore c'est tellement bon de vivre les
rêves je suis partie nicaise et fier de
l'être devenir une petite commune
s'appelle le macumba le mcs aubin est
bordée de falaises dominée par la
moutonne plais beaucoup de petites
maisonnettes à l'époque faisait face aux
armes
en général la rumba croit le pôle da luz
dans le monde scientifique
il vient de madagascar
c'est vrai
que cette petite ces petites
maisonnettes avec blizzard à l'arrière
de la maison parce qu'à l'époque la
cuisine était dépassé et des tâches et
la maison donc l'arbre était présente
c'était avec à présent pourquoi parce
que il était vital traite à vital était
hier c'était notre aire de jeux pour les
enfants c'était j'ai envie de le dire je
voulais relever services a pour la fin
et je vous le dis quand même je suis né
dans une bassine jusqu'à maintenant
macouba il n'y a pas de docteur d'un
combat existe encore mais a toujours pas
de médecins et les aînés qui nous qui
accouchent et nos parents en tire est
justement le placenta sur cet arbre d'où
le nom l'arbre à femmes
t'es pas du tout miss tic c'est vrai et
nos parents nous avaient toujours
expliqué que cet arbre
c'était vraiment un arbre nouble noble
pourquoi
à multifonctions on pouvait arracher les
feuilles pour se servir de benoni
décoration pis elle en avait besoin au
quotidien de la ficelle et puis
maintenant pourtant le toit des maisons
c'était comme ça ça se passait dans le
nord de la martinique c'est vrai ma
petite commune chéri ligue 1 pape à l
excellent album culte heures époque déjà
imaginez-vous trois décennies
je suis partie survenue après trois
décennies et il faisait déjà se lie les
betteraves et haricots verts des oignons
et des patates de dib et les patates des
pommes de terre d'oc ce papa m'avait
donné le goût de la nature des bonnes
choses des choses naturelles petit
tout ce que j'avais comme spectacle de
ma commune étaient tous les vendredis
soirs où passait un gros banc mais alors
un bac bougies en ébène ou qui m'inspire
l aventure mais quelle aventure
tous les vendredis nous t'aimons spectac
à moi je militais approprié et voilà que
j'ai décidé de partir mais partie en
partie pour aller où
partir oui il fallait que je parles tu
oui partir pour revenir
papa est rapide
bien sûr avec l'accord de mes parents je
suis parti mon rêve
il réalisa mais voilà un second au bac
bô toublanc appli opine ya 12 jours sous
la mer qu'est ce qui m'attendait je sais
que même partie avec ce panorama le
soleil la mer
l'odeur de mangue et de vanille et oui
déçu partie des jongles et beaucoup de
mes maîtres 80 avec la mauldre mêmes
voilà de retour au pays natal le pauvre
dans ma commune
pourquoi je suis venu pour quoique
survenu
je suis simplement revenus avaient bien
compris après toi dessinée simplement
pour m'inscrire au ministère du temps
libre c'est à dire la retraite légale
vacances n'a jamais été de la cance
travailler encore et quel bonheur
les breaks
vous êtes déjà parti et au retour n'a
rien trouvé de pareils ça vous est déjà
arrivé
vous avez déjà ouverts en album la
police faute ou vous reconnaissez pas
tout a changé
c'était mon cas c'était mon cas révèle
un problème
figurez vous que sur le balcon sous la
véranda de ma grand mère
en revenant bien sûr pays je dirais que
j'ai capté une image une compatriote
avec un bébé sur le prix paul et un
parapluie noir
là c'était plus un rêve un parapluie
noir plus pas pourquoi un parapluie noir
ç'aurait été une ombrelle et parapublic
j'aurais dit en guise nombre elle met un
parapluie noir
tout ça pour vous vous lire que toi
tellement changé et je suis partie avec
du soleil avec des odeurs de sucre de
vanille et me voilà revenu et gris
pourquoi y aller mais pourquoi pourquoi
pas réfléchir après infection
j'ai enfin compris que c'était mon
couvre-chef pas quoi qui était remplacé
par ce parapluie noir catastrophe
il fallait que je fasse les choses il
fallait que je remette ce couvre chef
c'est tarbes bat quoi dans les feuilles
servait aussi j'ai fait exprès de le
laisser pour la fin pour les chapeaux
non seulement la robe avait disparu le
couvre-chef avait disparu il y avait
quelques chapeaux chez les pêcheurs les
agriculteurs
voilà le couple s'était réduit à ça je
me suis un petit peu missionné au début
timide membres parce que le zélé qui
inclut petit mec qui faisait ce genre de
travail ne livrait pas du tout pas du
tout leur savoir faire
mais comme je suis une battante et user
de mon charme pour pouvoir avoir
simplement quelques buts notion cette
fille sage et c'est là que je me suis
dit c'est notre mission
ma mission a commencé j'ai envie de vous
lier que nous avons tous une mission top
une mission sur la terre nous passons à
côté des fois très souvent à côté vous
aussi
faites attention quand vous voyez un
patrimoine mourir un patrimoine de côté
parce que simplement ça vaut pas la
peine
j'ai envie de vous dire un pays sans
culture est un pays sans âme
à partir de ce moment où j'ai compris
que mon travail avait commencé
venez vous bien je me suis auto proclamé
ambassadrice du chapeau bas croix et
pour ça je suis là ce soir devant vous
merci donc j'ai dû franchement terre une
éducation une petite éducation
timidement
je me suis rappelé le monde villa est
lui qui avait dit que l'éducation ses
larmes la puissante vous faire avancer
les choses
donc après peut-être trois quatre mois
j'ai réussi je dis bien j'ai réussi donc
de suffire à coiffer tout l'été les buts
et martiniquaise en passant par
monseigneur méranville et j'en passe et
j'ai vécu tout le monde je me suis dit
attendit d'hyères le monde botafogo
croit maintenant
mais pourquoi ce chapeau bas quoi
n'étaient pas apportées
la raison est tellement simple il était
simplement trop grand et trop encombrant
simplement tout simplement d'autres il
est au repos et je me suis mise à
chapelière je vous vois madame là vous
savez j'ai envie de vous mettre une
capeline l'assaut la tête
il ya une belle de longs mois une belle
capé à ça j'ai envie de vous dire
apparemment une éducation et chapeau
n'est pas un encombrant chapeau c'est
une coiffe une femme doit garder son
chapeau n'est pour tous à table et fait
partout vous le devez garder votre
chapeau et c'est là c'est là que le bât
a blessé parce que les gens nous étions
persuadés parce que très souvent on
entend à temps on est un chapeau alors
moi je veux non chapeau fini la
silhouette d'une femme et c'est une
coiffe en europe ont enlevé le chapeau
et puis si vous essayez vous allez voir
elle facilite et d'être belle
mon dieu vous avez un chapeau vous
n'avez pas besoin d'aller chez le
coiffeur on vous et vous voyez votre
chapeau a pu ou partie de votre voiture
ou sauté de veau partir vous n'avez pas
besoin de dire on premiers cheveux
blancs je sais pas je suis pas bouclé et
caetera et caetera et heureusement y'a
pas longtemps que je lisais un magazine
y compris que chapeaute revient à la
mode et au galop dot
notre back droit est un produit noble
pourquoi le noble ce petit bout de
fibres se passe à la machine se lavent
semaine couture comme vous voyez je suis
habillé bakwa maroc je vais le passer à
la machine est un produit qui est
tellement noble je me dis mais mon dieu
est ce qu on est conscients et ont
franchement sur mieux conscient de cette
richesse que nous avons notre pays est
vrai on est jamais mettre mon pays ni
rennes j'ai envie aussi de vous dire le
travail que j'ai fait jusqu'à maintenant
il ya réseau maintenant exactement 13
ans dont je suis fier les élèves les
écoles même l'université et suisses
appelés
un peu partout pour le tressage l'art du
tressage pas quoique je savais pas
attention personne de me chez moi le
fait ça personne n'avait jamais touché à
sa rencontre
vous me voyez je suis même pas envie
d'être mauvaise j'ai envie de vous dire
avec un chapeau sur la tête des passants
plus belle tout simplement j'ai envie de
vous dire ça y est pourquoi pas vous
mais pourquoi pas vous franchement
madame de département
alors monsieur un petit borsalino le dj
mais bah quoi je dis bien bas quoi le
dis papa dame a essayé essayé de faire
revivre ce petit pan de patrimoine qui
est le chapeau bas toi la martinique est
frappé une petite crise économique mais
identitaire elle fait place un contrôle
de consommation tout le monde achète
n'importe quoi qui viennent d'ailleurs
alors que l'autre martinique devait être
vraiment une perle de production j'ai lu
tout ce mois passés avant moi
vous avez vu sept niches d'excellence
que nous avons menti ne voulait pas fier
d'être martiniquais
et moi je suis fier je suis encore plus
fier parce qu'on m'a gardé comme bouquet
final de ce grand événement le tedx d'un
an
ayez le réflexe dacquois j'ai envie de
vous le dire si je suis ici aujourd'hui
je vous ai dis pas que je rêve encore
martinique n'est pas si petit plaisir
pourquoi pas avec ses goules d'idées
elle doit grandir la souris ans
pourquoi ne pas mettre en place une
école dacquois pourquoi ils nicole bakwa
simplement tout à chacun viendront
s'initier à l'art va croire tout le
monde semble désertion une vitrine
vitrine pour les touristes et puis je
pense aux personnes qui ont un peu de la
street dance 3d telle façon
agréable et septune elle doit trouver
ces supplices la souplesse des doigts en
tressant alors vous rendez compte de ce
qu'on peut faire
le seigneur nous a préparés espaces
équipés où il manquait de rien nous
avons tous sapé vous mettre à la place
des artifices aujourd'hui tout le monde
se demande on le revenu comme avant mais
oui nos grands parents avaient raison on
peut encore si on veut on peut être
vraiment uniques 1 imports
alors mon rêve pour l'école jan
ceulemans que ça profiterait à tout le
monde il dans ce pays
nous manquons la base la base de savoir
faire mais de bien savoir faire pas du
savoir faire comme ça il savoir bien
faire les choses
oui bon coin ça c'est pour nous mêmes
non non non il faut qu'on arrête ça je
pense paradis avant moi mais je le
répète tout le temps alors je pense que
tu dises va m'aider à réaliser cette
grande idée de ma petite elle la petite
île qui est le pied la martinique avec
moi s'il vous plaît et il avait flex bah
quoi merci de m'envoyer
les